[MUSIC PLAYING]
What a great looking movie.
When's the next showing?
Can I see a preview?
[TROMBONE BLOWING]
Nowadays, nearly
everyone has the internet
in their pocket and access
to the world's information
at their fingertips.
However, getting and interacting
with that information
isn't always easy.
So where did I put
that bar code scanner?
Do I even have a bar
code scanner on here?
[TROMBONE FAIL SOUND]
However, if we believe
in Moore's law at all,
we can project that
there are going
to be millions of smart devices
in our homes, in our work,
and everywhere in between.
Accessing functionality
from these devices
can be just like using the web.
You just walk up, tap, and go.
Cool.
There's a show in
just a few minutes.
[VICTORY SOUND]
Hello, I'm Scott Jenson, and
this is the Physical Web.
So how does this work?
The poster is using a
Bluetooth low energy beacon
to broadcast a URL
once every second.
The device here can run for
five years on a single charge.
There's a simple scanner on
the phone that looks around
whenever you wake it up.
It won't do any scanning if
the phone is in your pocket.
The user must always ask to
see if anything is nearby.
If the scanner
discovers something,
it'll give you a
list to choose from,
ranked and filtered, to reduce
spam, and bring the most
relevant content to the top.
You select a web
page, and it opens,
just like clicking
on a search result.
One of the reasons we use
URLs is that they are very
well understood and flexible.
They can point to a simple web
page with information, a more
interactive web app,
or could even deep
link into a native
application in your phone.
As these beacons are really
just small computers,
the URLs can even
dynamically change,
reflecting a sensor value or
even an authentication token.
Check out this
parking meter example.
The user walks up
to it and pulls out
their phone to see a
list of nearby devices.
They tap on the parking meter
and are taken to a web page.
They just add the time
they want and hit Pay.
All of the billing is
taken care of in the cloud.
And once that's done, it
just authorizes the meter.
So what's happening here?
The Physical Web URL points to
a web page on a standard web
server that connects
to a small controller
here, inside the parking meter.
When the purchase
goes through, it
uses a WebSocket to
message the board,
which then adds the time.
While the movie poster took you
on a journey from the beacon,
to the phone, and then
straight to the web, here,
the parking meter completes
the loop interacting directly
with the machine
right in front of you.
All just using standard
web technologies.
I want to stress
this just a bit.
The Physical Web is only about
getting the URL to the phone.
Everything else after that
is just using the web.
In this example,
all of the real work
is done by using WebSockets.
That's the idea behind
the Physical Web.
Objects can broadcast
URLs wirelessly
to the area around them.
Anyone with a phone or a tablet
nearby can scan the area,
pick an object, and interact
with it on the spot.
Unlike most apps
today, the Physical Web
enables very small interactions,
things that you'd never
consider using an app for.
A dog collar can let
you find its owner.
A bus stop could tell you
when the next bus is coming.
You could rent a
bike, get a mall map,
or even watch a new tutorial
on a new home appliance.
The web is powerful
because it works so well
for the long tail.
Nearly anything could
have its own web page.
The value of the
web is having access
to millions of small web pages.
This same power can be
applied to smart devices
and even places.
Each one of these
Physical Web interactions
is moderately useful,
but taken together,
they demonstrate how letting
everything be interactive
opens up a new long tail
of ephemeral interaction
for the entire world around us.
The Physical Web is just an
extension of the existing web.
Like all web
technologies, it's open
and anybody can build on it.
Because it uses URLs as
the core building block,
the entire system
is decentralized,
so nobody controls it.
With the discovery of web
pages made frictionless,
we're excited to see what kind
of next generation experiences
developers like you will
build on top of the web.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]